hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and we are in round
10 of our coverage
of the 2021 candidates tournament to
race to see
who will face magnus carlsen for the
world championship later this year
i thought we'd do a video on the leader
of the tournament so far and that is yan
the pulmonic he is my dark horse if you
remember from a year ago in round one
i said i thought he would win the
tournaments he had a really good game
against denise geri
and he's been leading the entire way i
also think he has a really good shot at
beating
magnus carlson his opponent playing the
black pieces curiel alexinko
and he is middle of the pack but
definitely with a victory could
leapfrog a lot of the players and see
himself
near the top of the sitting so an
important game for both of these players
but we will go ahead and get started
with yon playing the white pieces with
pawn two
c4 now black plays knight to f6
and i almost always just expect that
it's going to be pawn to d4
they play this pawn to c4 teasing me
that they're going to play the english
opening but they never actually do but
jan said yeah i actually
am going to play the english opening so
pawn to g3 preparing to fianchetto the
bishop here to
jitsu so two e6 bishop here to g2
saw a similar type game yesterday in the
catalan opening when the bishop comes
here to g2 trying to control this light
square diagonal here
that's exactly what yon's gonna be
looking to do in the english opening as
well
pawn to d5 knight here to f3 says yeah i
don't mind if you take this pawn that's
fine so after the pawn takes queen up
here to a4
check and then preparing to capture this
pawn right here that's exactly what we
see
and then pawn to a6 preparing to push
forward with
pawn to b5 and this would kick back the
queen and also prepare for the bishop to
come here to b7
and really counter attack these light
squares
uh this diagonal that white's really
looking to control in the game so the
queen comes back here to c2 recognizing
that the pawn is going to be coming down
first we see pawn to c5 just trying to
control the center of the board
since white's going to be attacking the
light squares
black wants to go ahead and start
attacking with the dark squares here
knight to c3 just simple development
move bishop here to e7 prepare to castle
on the king side we see castle from both
sides
and then pawn up here to d4 what i
really like about this is because after
the exchange here the knight takes here
on
d4 and taking material while also
opening up for this light square bishop
to
control this long square diagonal this
long light square diagonal
is really really powerful for whites
because
if you look from black standpoint really
wants to get this light square
bishop involved into the game but now
really can't play the pawn anywhere
because then the rook's going to fall
here
this knight here on d7 is kind of
awkwardly placed it can't
come to a great outpost like c5 is not
really great outpost
knight to e5 not protected by any pawns
who can easily be pushed away
and then if you look at how does the
slight square bishop get involved into
the game
no real clear path unless you want to
use up one of your moves
to maybe play rook to b8 and then start
pushing forward with your pawn so really
good
uh it's a subtle move just to play up
here to d4 and exchange with that pawn
here
from c5 but i thought that ended up
extremely well
for yon now queen two c7
and we see rook over here to d1 just
activating that getting it to the center
of the board
this is a open file so we're definitely
trying to get the rooks over here to the
c file and
the the d file to really control those
long
files look over here to d8 from a black
as well
thinking the same thing and then bishop
here to e3 you can always push if you
want to but it does get kind of awkward
this is your only central pawn that you
have left
and then if they let's say knight to c5
all of a sudden both of their knights
are attacking this pond right here
uh and you aren't really going to have
any other protection
for this pawn except your minor pieces
you're not going to be pushing forward
with
let's say f3 because you really need and
the especially when you fianchetto to
the king side of the board
usually like to keep this structure and
so pawn to e4 just doesn't make
as much sense as you would normally see
in a chess opening so instead bishop
here to e3
and then knight here to b6 followed by
rook to c1 just getting both of these
rooks
in the center of the board controlling
these open files
now black decides to go ahead and attack
the knight here in the center of the
board so pawn here to e5 but as we
talked about similar to white here
this pawn on e5 is going to be difficult
for black to hold on to from protection
standpoint
this knight here on f6 is blocking the
pawn so this pawn's not going to be
pushing forward does not have
his d-pawn here so that's not going to
be able to protect it so yes this is
definitely forcing the knight to move
but definitely something that white can
attack later in the game
so knight two f5 and then after the
bishop takes queen takes here
then knight to c4 this is attacking both
the bishop here on e3
and the pawn to b2 bishop comes up here
to a g5
attacking the knight now if you look at
say well yeah i was attacking the bishop
so maybe he doesn't want to give up his
bishop hair
which is a huge advantage for white here
but it also leaves this pawn here on
b2 but black really can't take that and
so you always have to really think about
what happens if
material takes and so after the knight
takes here on b2 what we would see
is knight to d5 you can see
lots of stuff is happening right here
this is attacking the queen both with
the knight and the rook here on
c1 but it's also putting a lot of
pressure on this
f6 square now probably the best move is
just to go ahead and take this material
knowing that you eventually are going to
lose a lot of material but
after the rook takes here you can see
all of a sudden
we have the two rooks here for white
black had to give
up a rook attacking the queen still from
this rook here on c once after the queen
moves
you can see an exchange right here but
then rook to c8 forces the other rook to
come off the board and things get pretty
difficult for
black here you can see the lights where
bishop can now get involved into the
game
and there's just too much pressure on
black
to really do anything i want you to have
a pretty easy game so if we come back
the knight is not going to be taking
that pawn here on v2 that would be a big
mistake so instead we see
the rook coming down taking here on d1
we see the knight come back to
d1 also protecting this pawn here on b2
so you always we
want to be thinking about how you can
take material or get out of the way
while also posing a threat or defending
one of your pieces as well that's
exactly what knight to d1 does
even though normally you don't want to
bring your material back this
knight coming back to d1 definitely
protects this also opens up for the rook
to really control this c
file so the knight can't move here
because then the queen would fall
it just puts a lot of pressure on black
now the rook comes over here to
d8 don't know that this is really the
best move maybe queen to
uh d8 getting it off this c file i think
makes a
a lot of sense here because yes if they
just take the knight here that's fine
the queen could just come down and take
the knight here on
d1 so i always like finding the threats
that your opponent has and trying to
minimize what they can do
so i would probably play queen here to a
d8
but black decided to go ahead and play
rook to d8
bishop takes here on f6
there is an exchange right here and then
bishop here to
e4 and you can see the threat it's queen
to h7 this is check now not checkmate
if the rook was over here on f8 that
would be checkmate the king can still
come over here
but it loses the pawn of material and
you're just gonna be chasing the king
around the board
black decides okay we're not gonna worry
about that right away i'm gonna play
queen 2a5 if you want to take my pawn
over here i'm going to go ahead and take
your pawn here on
a2 and so white says okay if you want to
do that i don't want to lose my pawn so
i'm just going to bring my knight up
here to
c3 this also gets it out of harm's way
from the rook if
it ever wants to come down here as well
also you can see the threat from black
is also just playing queen
to e1 check so not only attacking this
pawn right here so this move on knight
to c3 does
a lot of stuff for white here including
protecting this pawn
and white still has that threat here on
h7 so
king comes to f8 yes you are going to
lose material
at some point but you are getting your
king out of harm's way as quick as
possible
white says yeah i don't just want a pawn
i want the entire game so i'm just going
to get more material involved
into the attack so knight 2 d5 here
always good to centralize your attackers
and you can see
it's got a nice little outpost from this
light square bishop the dark square
bishop
can't attack this d5 square and this
knight here on
c4 it's not really doing anything right
now as far as attacking it
either now it could come back if it
wants to but decides to go and push
forward here with
b5 then queen takes here on h7 we knew
it was coming at some point
rook decides to go ahead and take here
on d5 and if you look and say you know
why would you give up
a rook for a night here well not all is
lost because after the rook takes and
the bishop takes then queen down
to d2 definitely going to get material
back here because you can see the
queen's attacking the rook here on c1 as
well as the bishop here on
d5 so no way to hold on to the material
so just just decide to go ahead and take
material here on
c4 blow up this pawn chain a little bit
anytime you are looking for an exchange
see how you can
make your opponent end up with a worse
position and so now there's
two isolated pawns here so going into
the end game white definitely has
better pawn structures as the pawns are
connected more so than black
both sides do have a bishop but they are
different color bishops so i have
another video if you ever wanted to
watch and see
how that in game compares to some other
end games
specifically if they were on the same
colors light square or dark squares
definitely plays different so
pawn 2 e4 so this is a great outpost for
this bishop here on a d5 really blocks
off where this queen can go to and how
it can maneuver around the board
queen takes here on b2 queen up here to
h8
check king here to e7 and then queen
over here to
c8 attacking this pawn right here
attacking this pawn here on
a6 and preparing for a threat on this
king here
exposed in the center of the board
now understanding the threat black comes
back here to
b6 queens takes here on c4
and this is preparing for the bishop to
come up take here on f7 with
more threats coming after that queen 2
b5 says i'm not looking to exchange
at all uh jan definitely thinks he has
the upper hand
queen here to c7 queen up here to d7 and
then queen to
c5 check and in this position black
decided to
resign i think it's a little premature
to resign now do i think helen's going
to win absolutely does he have the upper
hand
absolutely would it be difficult to
defend this absolutely should he resign
in this position i don't think so
because it's not the
easiest and i don't think you have
anything to lose to play this out and
maybe
maybe you could get a draw out of it and
so sometimes people say
how would this even end in a win for
for white here okay well we have check
one variation could be
king comes back here to d8 king here to
g2
just getting out of harm's way if queen
ever comes down to
uh the first rank here maybe bishop to
e7
uh attacking the queen queen two b6
check
queen over here c7 gobbling out material
now there's a pass pawn
makes it a little bit easier king to e8
and then a4 and it's tough to push or
to stop this push here on the the a file
i don't know
exactly how it would go but black
decided did not want to
play anymore so congratulations dion he
still leads the tournament now
by a full point with four rounds to go
it definitely looks like
he is in the driver's seat he's playing
some phenomenal chess so curious to see
if he can continue
um while i do have some others that i am
cheering for in the tournament
i really want to see a good matchup
against madness carlson
and out of all the players i really
think that yon has the best chance to
beat him
and if that gives us the best world
championship later in the year
i'm definitely going to be a fan of that
just being a chess fan so thank you guys
so much for watching round 10
and i will see you guys next time for
round 11.